dans les pubs pourquoi pas un château ah
oui c'est quand même notre mariage quant
à un groupe et pourquoi pas dès
lors la vie je m'occupe du
château du dj de la calèche tout tu
devais choisir et la bouffe et tu prends
des knacki mais tu m'avais dit oui
mesdemoiselles bilingue tout le monde
aime bien les knacki non attendez vous
allez où là ouais moi je suivais gagnent
alors je mets moi je mange pas de porc
revenir moi pour le gâteau a renchéri le
gâteau éléphanteaux naquit aussi
officielle dans les pubs
quad cross et vous les gourmands votre
journée vous l'a commencé comme ans
raconte dans la vie
crac crac
crac crac j'ai compris le message jérôme
ducros nomme robin
dans les pubs d'ailleurs vous avez une
alarme oui en effet installé vers 6h et
la caméra ça faut bien sûr il a
déclenché quelques uns c'est nous qu'on
mange les rendez vous sur very sur point
fr dans la vie d'ailleurs vous avez
d'ailleurs oui on n'a pas installé vers
est sûre et la caméra c'est pour
ce qu'elle aime bien anon on n'a pas
parlé de caméras elle est pourquoi la
salle alors globalement
on est vidé depuis le début en fait
c'était une caméra cachée
dans les pubs à tous les jours cette
fichue poussière utiliser un chiffon la
galère c'est pourquoi je suis passé à
suivre dans la vie utilisez un chiffon
la galère c'est quoi ton problème
maintenant c'est le chiffon la galère tu
prends tu les aimes tu es suit et tu
reposes
pas besoin de swiffer plus du
tout en fait non faut juste être moins
cons dans les pubs
seck va de stress
drama facture est en baisse ben ainslie
pas ouf le ça marche pas non il
est tout neuf où il marche très bien
regardes
tu vois faut qu'on avait le service
après-vente u ne touche plus aux
assiettes d'accord ont fait danser
encore une petite aucune on ne peut pas
le faire avec moi c'est hyper drôle fais
comme tu veux parce que je divorce
entre les pubs ça fait mon papa un jour
il m'a dit que lui aussi il a une arme
secrète
power dans la vie c'est quoi ce bordel
c'est mon gamin il a pris ma chaussure
pour l'école vous foutez de ma gueule ou
coûts annoncées pourront exposer mais
qui fait des exposés sur des chaussures
de chantier l'an de dios et j'en ai
marre tu gamin il m'énerve vous êtes
viré je comprends dans les pubs mais
lucas ou frau mois sept pays non arabe
insisté quoi t'as pas craquer bravo bébé
chez 3,5 à contacter ou positif
l'important c'est de s'isoler vraiment
dans la vie palais le cha ouvre-moi s'te
plaît non pas un peuple légitimes j'en
aurai pas vous encaissez vont rester
mais sa volée parti attendait c'était
meuf le ouais j'ai dit que j'étais cas
contacts comme ça on est tranquille à
voter mais du coup qu'est ce qu'ils
foutent elle alors elle voulait vérifier
que on se voyait bien pas c'est
ouais t'as pas craquer bravo mon bébé je
suis fier de toi supercherie super hyper
faire de nous mêmes oui il t'aime très
fort dans les pubs fait le premier pas
vers la confidentialité en ligne obtenez
la meilleure offre de l'enppi plein dans
la vie vous pouvez utiliser norvez peine
pour protéger vos données mais aussi
pour changer votre localisation pour
accéder à d'autres contenus sur les
flics sous accéder à des événements
sportifs sur la formule 1 par exemple et
en s'écriant c'est c'est pas du tout une
parodie de pub non ça c'est une vraie
pub comme dans la vraie vie des vrais pu
parfois assez fort et je sais vous
pouvez cliquez sur lire dans la
description norvégienne points comme
saint cyprien pour avoir une course très
dure qui est un petit cadeau s'est
satisfait ou remboursé pendant trois
jours cette saison très fort dans les
pubs dit non à jeter
dit oui à réparer dit oui à loctite dans
la vie c'est carrément écologique de
réparer en fait c'est écologique tu
viens de commander un tube de colle
thema le carton tu penses un peu aux
transports aux camions tout ce que tu as
utilisé pour un crime de quelques temps
on peut acheter en bas de la rue dans
les pub optic 2000 d'achat ma mère a
besoin de lunettes mais un peu plus
déplacée pas de problème c'est nous qui
nous déplaçant chez elle bon je vous
laisse je vais la voir
dans la vie je vous laisse je vais
l'avoir à l'eau je vous voulez pas
l'adresse vous ai pas donné adresses
mails et coups de mer dans les pubs tout
le monde me connaît
et mme adore
justin bridou vivre et groupe partouche
ton avis donc tout le monde me connaît
et m'adore ouais elle va dire ne pas y
passer la nuit bonjour
tu écris c'est pas moi tu as juste
écrire un truc que tu avais sous les
yeux la fête qu'est ce que t'es pas
drôle et quand on joue à ce jeu tu
imagines quelque chose d'autre pour
s'amuser tu écris par un truc qui est
devant toi propose quelque chose d'autre
de cette mais il est nul
dans les pubs à toi tu dirais combien
220 me combien ces moines on sait
combien pour mon bien point fr gens
battent
tout à fait jean badge en battant dans
la vraie vie décente me tallend combien
je suis rentré par route et qui monsieur
là bas je suis ton pas de jambes at the
top les ont battus est une propriété
privée ici monsieur oui on va appeler la
police 1 n'ont pas encore la
police et l'asile d'à côté j'avais
oublié mais 110 mille cinq cent mille 11
mars à sanaa dans les pubs qui sait qui
fait quoi
tu as entendu parler du plastique qui
polluent les océans se fait rire avec
sodastream l'eau du robinet devient
pétillant dans la vie tu fais quoi ta je
crois tu as entendu parler du plastique
qui polluent les océans en foyer se veut
plus de plastique bas très bien on va
tomber toutes les poupées alors des
baskets sont en plastique aussi on va
trouver des baskets en carton ça va
faire fureur à l'école quelqu'un pour sa
carrière aller dans ta chambre mais pas
d'enfants mais c'est un accident dans
les pubs donc la forêt tu vois un rayon
de lumière taper dans les feuillages
tension au max et là ils débarquent
sortie nulle part tout le magnifique et
le truc de dingue un sanglier mon frère
mais tu dis des trucs de ouf à la charge
avec la chef retrouver votre vraie
nature dans la vie y est là y débarquent
magnifique un sanglier mon frère tu la
butte et du coup là je te parlais de la
forêt la lumière dans la forêt la
lumière ça s'appelle se balader en forêt
quand tu te bats d'enfants être croisé à
son gré son cutter statut la butte et
moi j'aime bien buter les animaux avec
un fusil quand ils passent pas mesuré
battait plus c'est plus ça ça fait peur
à tout le monde qu'on t'en parles ok on
les pubs et toi c'est vrai quoi toi
frérot avec 130 millions moi je je
partagerai avec vous c'est quoi ça
on a tous gagné tout ce qui est non la
vie et toi frérot tu ferais quoi avec
130 millions d'euros je
ne partagerai avec vous
c'est toi qui as gagné on a tous gagnés
[Musique]